what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation I have and haven't been
this excited so long because I'm here
because Andrew's here we have talked
countlessly over the years about the
last of us as massive fans of the game I
was like I want to experience this as a
gamer fan with my closest friend who I
talked about you know I'm trying to get
out here we're gonna watch The Last of
Us today people I am thrilled Andrew how
excited are you I am so pumped I've been
actually playing both games about back
to back I'm just so knee-deep in Last of
Us right now and I'm just so pumped and
so excited for this show what's really
important to me is I give you guys a
heads up though and I don't want anyone
who hasn't played the games to worry
that Andrew and I like spoiling anything
that might happen in future episodes
We're not gonna do any Telegraph in that
regard so when it comes to talking about
the show or how pretense of the game
we're only going to keep it about the
episode itself we will not do anything
about what's supposed to happen down the
road or what might happen so if you
haven't played the game don't worry you
can still hang out with us here but if
you have played the game you might
appreciate being here with us too also
John and Tara Erickson have not played
the game but they will be doing
reactions for the channel to provide you
with a non-gamer perspective leave a
like that's what we really ask you right
now please go ahead leave a like
subscribe click that notification Bell
notify when I react for the next episode
last of us is up as always the full
length Reaction watch along as we sync
up with your own copy available for our
super sexy rejects on our patreon page
we cover a bunch of stuff exclusively
with reaction highlights and Watch Dogs
included over there I just want to get
the ninja out of the way let's go to it
[Applause]
and that's your biggest worry yes any
kind of virus but most probably
something similar to influenza
we end up with a global pandemic and
meaning all the whole world becomes
sickle at once damn that's Jonathan Hyde
yeah you do think microorganisms pose a
threat or in the most dire terms
bacteria no oh Silicon Valley not
viruses so fungus
because there are some fungi who seek
not to kill but to control
interesting the fungus needs food to
live so it begins to devour its host
from within who sat in the stage fungi
cannot survive if it's host's internal
temperature is over 94 degrees what if
the world was to get slightly warmer ah
to spread the infection to every last
human alive by any means necessary
so if that happens we lose
[Music]
I love how they made it more relevant
yeah who will be back I think like
global warming and stuff that's
interesting
[Music]
yes
[Music]
look at the fun guy such good music I
love that opening oh yeah they're being
worn decades in advance
[Music]
that's
a great title opening
I already have chills
oh
wow we're starting way earlier I mean
like with Sarah like in the day oh yeah
yeah yeah I'm just gonna make your
birthday pancakes oh
vitamin C
Joel loves his coffee how old are you
again 36.
gonna have to wear diapers soon he says
I don't already
stay alive yo oh he loves you he's
dependent on me not the same definitely
the same if I was having pancakes this
sounds exactly like him it does oh my
goodness
Jakarta such a cool little detail right
there definitely a country maybe part of
Asia your part isn't a country being a
part of Asia is mutually exclusively
being a country and in fact it's capital
of Indonesia damn she's smart your
t-shirt's inside out
hahaha
spooky looks just like the house yeah
yeah it does
oh the watch yeah Connie was asking
after you that you hadn't been over in a
while
make him happy get to know the neighbors
we gotta run but Sarah will be by later
she'll stay as long as you want tell you
all about Atkins
thank you
how exciting it was listen to that the
conversation
I want you to write this diagram out
exactly as I have it okay we were
watching this
in time clock
[Music]
smart whole first episode from Sarah's
perspective which is in conjunction with
the actual game
I also love too that we get to see the
lead up on the first day it's really
cool
[Music]
love it the apocalypse is just building
okay so we cannot finish I'm already
finished
oh no
oh the tone just so changed there was
just a lot of police and stuff on the
road today people out there need to get
right with Jesus three Nails Plus One
cross equals four given Jesus would have
stopped them
there's so much emphasis on the ticking
time clock yeah I love it
be right there
oh no
that's creepy
[Music]
hey Mrs Adler can I borrow this oh
that's creepy
dogs can detect oh yeah
killer Sarah
wow
[Music]
where's the cake
you got me in prison swear
oh my love
it's great fix it for you
did you what I don't hear anything
that was lame
yeah nice where'd you get the money for
this
drugs I saw hardcore drugs
and you were never gonna do it for
yourself so
thank you
it's funny hard it feels like it's the
first time you're hearing it it doesn't
feel like they're just recreating it
apart from the adlers oh this is the one
with the deleted scenes yeah uh
it's me uh I'm okay
it's Friday you don't get me out tonight
I'm in here all weekend
idiot damn it tell me
[Music]
what's this on the clocks he has a lot
of time
[Music]
wow
damn really sure briefly woke her up to
at least tell her
that's the details
indoors law enforcement and emergency
services are in the area and we'll be in
contact with further instructions
[Music]
let the dog in
love how they just keep it from a
grounds view perspective on the rising
of the military coming in and stuff
come on let's get you home oh no come on
Mercy please
Mercy
[Music]
oh [ __ ] it's like John Carpenter
directed this Mrs Adler
whoa
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh my God
Ray reveal
[Music]
oh the hair in the mouth
[Music]
oh
won that [ __ ]
oh dear
[Music]
oh okay
what are we doing Joe
[Music]
now at the sound design and the weapon
so just the adlers but we're going to be
brave and we're going to get out of this
I really like the how they changed that
up yeah that was good Denise you get
back inside the house you lock your
doors now come on come on get in
oh man
Sarah's perspective oh that's great yeah
get your seatbelt on hold on
this is awesome
[Music]
oh wow oh yeah
you're saying it's mostly people in the
city that's why they got the highway
blocked up I am loving this oh look at
that oh God damn
it's Jimmy's Place
before I feel like they're choosing the
right [ __ ] to be faithful with yeah
keep trapping oh I got a kid so do we
keep driving
[Music]
somebody else will come along
everybody had the same [ __ ] idea
cut across and pick up on the west side
all right hang on
[Music]
dude this is awesome
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] Army
Tommy come on
call the razor crest
Harbor blockade him around
fantastic capturing of the mood
whoa
holy crap
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
move
move
oh my God
damn
oh wow that was a nice change
[Music]
liquor noise well there can't be
clickers yeah I think it's uh
foreshadowing
don't
gotta say this first 30 minutes is the
best video game adaptation so far
in Mortal Kombat
oh man
head to the river I'll find a way
get her out of here Joe go dude these
actors are killing it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
man it's got the horror element down
damn stunt work here
shooting my daughter's hurt her ankle
stop right there
yes sir
yes sir
yes sir
we're not sick
sir
we are not sick
I'm sorry
please stop
[Music]
okay you're okay you're okay move your
hand baby move your hand
[Laughter]
s
[Music]
I know I know I know I know baby I know
I know
you're gonna be okay all right maybe
maybe listen to me I gotta get you up
all right come on you come on I know
baby no no I know I know I know [ __ ]
[Music]
come here no it's good hey let's
heartbreaking goddamn yeah [ __ ]
she was great very good she was great I
was like really invested in her yeah
smartly the expansion on her
[Music]
holy God wow
I should create some type of immersion
experience
[Music]
that is nuts oh
Flawless what if I told you that after
we gave you some medicine we're gonna
find you your favorite food to eat would
you like that waffles
you're safe
my name is Abby
Show's really smart it's taking the time
to do uh with his expansions to explore
the lifestyles more that's why you gotta
tap them in the shows
can't
oh my god
wow dude Pedro Pascal's excellent of
capturing the contrast
rations I love it
hey crew 4 pm start
[Music]
Gustavo Santa so good
[Music]
infection
I love how there's so much set re
creation
it's like real extras and real costumes
yeah real production just really feels
lived in
come on
[Music]
I just got a factory down there in the
qz supposedly only makes two things
pills and bullets bullets and pills the
more you shoot people the harder it is
to sleep I guess
the back back
I love the expansion on the smuggling
stay off the streets for the next few
nights the Firefly has been blowing [ __ ]
up all week
did you make a mistake in the dark
stay safe
yeah you too it just looks like Joel
[Music]
when you're lost in the darkness look
for the blood
[Music]
Robert it's not like I planned on
ripping you off how about we just let it
go
oh my guys [ __ ] you up you're so
discipline them and cut off her finger
or whatever the [ __ ] you want I don't
care that you're [ __ ] guys
the key answers to me she won't hurt you
and I'd like to go home and drink till
my face stops hurting
oh damn
I could see an explosion coming in there
well that guy got disciplined
God damn
you're shooting you're shooting at us
right
definitely different and I like how
you're capturing the uh
oh here we go
emotionally tortured tesses
count slowly and clearly from one to ten
one two three four slowly seven
eight
you let me out are you gonna
pick
I'm not supposed to be here if Tommy
responded we'd know it's never taking
more than a day to respond
I'm sure he's okay actually staying in
contact with Tommy show where the tower
is Joel it's in Wyoming
Cody Tower qbar4 but I don't know
exactly
[Music]
he got you a cigarette never stop trying
to protect Tommy
[Music]
[Music]
glorious weapons now like in the game do
after a few hits they just stop working
or is he like
[Music]
this is an interesting touch more of an
alcoholic this time around just a little
more
[Music]
is more real
[Music]
thank you
and we're back in the game
[Music]
like how they're leaning more into the
Romantic side of these two
I got jumped
the guys who jumped me away with Robert
I need the battery if I don't get to
Tommy soon he's gonna die out there okay
okay we get our money back and the
battery eventual interesting rewrite
well where is he don't know are we gonna
find out quietly
yeah
I promised Robert that he wouldn't hurt
him but I would very much like for you
to hurt him
so let's go hunt that [ __ ] down
and then we'll go find Tommy smart
inclusion it makes it feel more personal
the mission yeah to go after Robert not
that it's just a job it's actually
there's a purpose and a reason behind it
oh Dandridge Marlene yeah it's so cool
they got the same actress we are in a
war against a military dictatorship to
restore democracy and freedom to the
sound about right does look like her
yeah every Firefly in Boston is going to
gather in this building and you're gonna
leave the qz we're taking that random
girl locked in that room West
is this real
I believe it is goddamn right it's real
keep it quiet
look at her where she needs to go
[Music]
just changed her whole optimism
I like the different ways they choose to
introduce these characters but then it
still segues into the game yeah will
give us more expansion now when you play
the game you're like oh maybe this
character was doing that even though
there are obviously different things
that they're doing here
different which is a good show it's a
good show yeah yeah if you're feeling
lost tell me to look for the line I'll
break your Journal
he Robert by surprise
they got the foul mouth down she's
capturing the essence really well
[Music]
but also the relationship between them
capturing it earlier is it gonna happen
no so can I go
no not exactly where are you gonna go
back to Federal military school
they put me there when I was a baby it's
for Orphans they didn't put you there I
did oh Ellie
Ellie I wish terrorist dumped me with
Federal because it's where you'd be
safest and you were safe there until you
decided to sneak out a terrorist was
Riley a terrorist oh I have a greater
purpose than anything
ever imagined
what I'm about to tell you cannot be
repeated to anyone because if you do I
assure you you will die you are the Cure
Ellie
[Music]
the sound I know right at the sound
design is so good
[Music]
oh
so scary that you're in places like this
with infected I just love getting the
expansion on the characters like this
hint at the history and the games but
you get to really see it now like how
Marlene and Ellie became becoming her
actual friend
[Music]
Dan that looks great you think he came
down after he was infected
maybe down here is where he was infected
I put your mask on grass once they spot
the spores they will looks like they
reframed the whole structure everyone
was cutting down on apartment sizes to
sell more condos this has been
construction corner with Joel Miller
you smell that
[Music]
oh okay that's Robert right is it I
didn't catch his face looked like Robert
couldn't
the battery's no good
still tried to sell it yeah huh
oh he just stumbled upon this huh
oh
Joel So It Begins so this is who Robert
screwed us over with the che guevar of
Boston
give me my knife what do you need a car
battery for
dope not at her
[Laughter]
we're gonna move Ellie out of the Zone
tonight so now I'm thinking
you're gonna do it I can do it you don't
have a [ __ ] you're on your head could
you please
oh yeah geez I don't know what you're
both capable of
the better or worse
what are they capable of
they'll give you what you name it not
just a battery the whole thing
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
really capturing the spirit of Ellie
unfortunate vehicle usually means
repurpose Venture stuff the second we
hand that kid over y'all talk it through
but please remember that I'm bleeding
out
nice nice but before we hand her over
they give us everything that we want if
not we kill her remember what I told you
no go get your backpack
the new stipulations of this deal
[Music]
made some wine changes makes it more
immediate Joel
I'm glad they got the same actors back
for that she's excellent I actually
really like the chemistry with uh her
and Nelly and also Joel and Marlene uh
Joel and uh Tess yeah you really get
that history of Survivor trauma bonding
with them
the Journey Begins
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
truly reckon I'd like this show even if
I hadn't played the game but if you can
score two people who are so invested in
the game that's that's a good sign so
who's Bill and Frank Bill and Frank what
are you doing
killing time what am I supposed to do
I'm sure you'll figure that out
your watch is broken
so we're gonna be okay
yeah
she has great lighting too so what's the
deal with you anyway you some kind of
bigwig's daughter or something
well the radio came on when you're
sleeping they kept saying like wake me
up before you go go oh [ __ ]
gotcha
code broken
such a smart ass I love it it's time to
go
sneaking time
ugly's got a smuggle
holy [ __ ] I'm actually outside
[Laughter]
close your phone
yeah yeah of course
let's go
it really like nailed casting from oh
yeah everyone yeah they're all so
believable you bring the likeness to
life and if you haven't played the game
in life they're believable you know
[Music]
I love the camera work in this too
oh I wonder if that's the same cop that
Joel spoke to earlier
oh there you go yeah you let us do this
run we'll split the cards with you but
will you yeah I'm so blessed and on your
head eyes forward hey
really man yep you're going to buy the
book
oh [ __ ] yeah I'm here
[ __ ]
we can fix this move
[Music]
yeah I was just thinking that yep oh
damn dude
damn pull it back Joel's got a mean
right hook pull it back
oh already I'm protecting the dog
look look this is three weeks old nobody
that's more than a day
I love the look he gave back did I make
the right call
[Music]
buddy
uh
interesting choice to break perspective
and come back here
holy crap that's such a great shot damn
it's gonna lightning flash yeah oh yeah
ah that was a damn quick uh one hour 19
minutes yeah that was excellent man that
was
that was excellent I was absorbed yeah I
couldn't take my eyes off the screen I
was so into that I mean you made a
really good point like even if you were
not a Die Hard fan or you had never
played the video games like you could
still watch the show not knowing
anything and still find a way to get
invested in these characters and and
enjoy the World building that was
happening here but on the other hand if
you are someone who is obsessed with
these video games like
they just like my biggest thing and this
is not meant to be a whole Disney like I
can't stand those live-action remakes
that they make Beauty and the Beast uh
Aladdin and all that like I I respect
the visuals in those films but a lot of
times they they're just
carbon copies and like every time I'm
watching a lot of those films I'm like
all right respect the filmmakers I love
these actors but this just feels like an
exact carbon copy remake of what I've
seen originally whereas this yeah they
paid respect and homage in certain areas
and I'm sure the rest of the show is
going to do it if if this first episode
uh you know is has shown what it can do
but just as a reminder we won't talk
about anything yeah yeah in the future
I'm not yeah I'm not I'm just I was just
saying for foreshadowing but I just love
like the stuff that they included the
stuff that they left out like it wasn't
a case of like maybe if you're a
die-hard Harry Potter fan and you read
the books like ah they didn't include
that or they've left that out it's like
no they actually did a really good job
of it's expanding a lot of things that
were talked about in quick conversation
in the first game but then really like
we got to see certain things like the
whole first day of the breakout like
from Sarah's perspective the whole build
up the tension building and then really
getting invested and Sarah like
obviously if you play the game you're
still saddened about by what happens
there but I felt myself like it like
really really extra sad in this just
because again we got the whole day to
spend with her like and she's such a uni
is such an interesting character she's
really unique she's curious she's smart
uh she's got a great relationship with
her dad they've got that cute Bond ship
that they have with each other and and
then obviously the relationship the
three of them have but I thought this
show this first episode was just just a
great way to start this off and I mean I
I'm really a harsh judge on this just
because it's my second favorite video
game of all time for anyone who doesn't
know I've mentioned that before but I
thought this was a great introduction
first episode introduction for I mean
for those who haven't played the game
like it starts off uh on Sarah but it's
it's like at the scene on the couch
basically that's the watch yeah yeah
let's see on the couch with the watch
and then as opposed to going to the
neighbors you know Sarah wakes up I'm
forgetting the one part I'm forgetting
he doesn't go Bale Tommy out of jail is
that no I don't remember any of that in
the game he was just at he ran back into
the house and then the neighbors
attacked and then Tommy and then Tommy
kept on calling on the cell phone yeah
they attack
um Joel and Sarah's house yeah the
neighbors and then Tommy shows up versus
how it sort of plays out here but I like
how they did here because they a lot of
times it seemed like a lot of the
choices they said were like how can we
make this feel more involved how can we
make this feel more personal rather than
Sarah just being scared with the
neighbor attacking let's get to know the
neighbors so we can see some of the
emotional repercussions that come with
it like I noticed a lot with the the
characters that he got with the infected
you would focus a lot on their eyes so
you would see a lot of the horror of the
reactions that you get from our our
protagonists but then you'd see a lot of
the Menace in the eyes of the infected
and I thought that was a smart execution
because it does yeah the way they
expanded time here uh allows you to just
become more more invested and have
things feel more personal
like I loved everything with Marlene uh
not Marlene sometimes I fluctuate the
name loved everything with uh Joel and
Tess because yeah they don't I mean it's
obvious in the game that like
something's romantic yeah but but you
kind of get the sense like it's it's
it's still super romantic or is it like
once in a while they kind of hook up you
know but here is no they're practically
like living together and they really
care more for each other like I like the
touch of like looking at her eyes and
how he's just like ready to like
get revenge for them right away and so
that was that was a very neat touch and
everything about it they had like the
Recreations of the the what they were
really capturing the most here that is
so important because yeah they
it's not the kind of thing if I I find
this finding my words right now I find
this whole experience really fascinating
because it's as if they're aware this
game is massive so there's gonna be some
[ __ ] that we're gonna have to be very
faithful to and so they're doing this
they I think for a first episode they
really nailed it in a way that I feel
like would make video game fans happy
and make people who are not familiar
with the game happy and that's a really
hard thing to do yeah and most video
game adaptations suck at that especially
ones like Last of Us which are such an
involved story where this the cut scenes
and the cinematics are such an intricate
part of it and so it does play on The
Nostalgia Factor but it's not the way
they weave in the uh the expansions in
the other scenes feel necessary for the
show experiences if you just did a
one-to-one adaptation it wouldn't work
as well and it would just feel like a
carbon copy like you talking about
whereas here
it may and manages to make those scenes
where I'm like that is exactly the video
game
still feel refreshing still feel unique
and not just I'm watching the game it
actually has an emotional effect versus
I'm watching the same beats happen again
because of what they decide to change
because of what they decide to weave in
there because they are capturing the
mood and the experience so so well and
uh I I I I I love this I actually
thought this was a really strong pilot
for for as a as a massive fan of the
video game but just as a fan of like
damn good television yeah like it's just
really good it's really good TV like
another touch they added because they
they don't I love the inclusion of what
they did there at the end with with uh
with the Joel in the guard yeah because
that's it that's great that's in the
game but they don't they don't do the
flashback right they yeah they don't
they know the Flash no it's just Ellie
just stabs him and then they shoot and
that's it and then why are we in why are
we smuggling an infected girl there's no
none of the you know all the Joel having
the flashback and then all the grief
just bottling up and then he takes it
out on that Garden none of that was in
in the game but yeah but it also tells
you for like a pilot like on a pie for a
first episode it's really smart because
it's cueing in the audience for
thematically what these characters are
going to be going on in the journey of
what Joel will be going on like it's
telling the audience right there they're
like I'm just to be safe I won't say it
but it's pretty obvious you know the
surrogate daughter thing you know
um I I thought that was a wonderfully
wonderfully done there are some stuff
that like they obviously changed you
know with Robert there's like a whole
mission yeah yeah it's completely gone
um also too they made Joel uh an
alcoholic in this uh it feels into that
yeah I mean like in the game yeah I mean
but now actually seeing it and you know
seeing popping pills it just it feels
more personal and you can relate to his
situation a lot more like actually
seeing it rather than being hinted at it
so I actually like that inclusion I also
love the whole really expanding upon the
I mean obviously we saw in the beginning
of the game them being in the qz in
Boston so we understand that there is
martial law but like seeing a
totalitarian government and like the
ramifications of what can happen
obviously we did see hints of or we saw
stuff of that in the game but actually
seeing and then seeing all the extras
around like this would really suck to
live in this world and like that
captures the coldness and the brutality
yeah for sure and and also too I really
thought they did a phenomenal phenomenal
job of just really Shifting the tone
like on the first day of outbreak like
you know something's about to happen but
it's cheerful you're in a good mood and
then like you start like when things
start going sideways like the mood just
again like you feel the tension you feel
like how dour it gets and just I just
thought this show just really nailed
that balance and the sound design in
this episode was Alaska and a lot of the
characters too you you nailed that they
they got the likenesses down and they
just they know they just sounded like
them
Luna has taught me too oh my goodness uh
Gabriel Gabriel Lunas I'm sorry Gabriel
in my back Gabriel Luna I mean it like
goodness gracious that's the weird part
because it doesn't sound like
impersonations that's natural they sound
like they're really they're great
performers
they're living that lived like you said
lived in they're they are the characters
but they don't sound like they're
impersonating them definitely which is
kind of the worry that you run into but
like I don't know how they managed to
[ __ ] nail that because even with like
like because you know I I uh it's funny
because you said um Diego Luna who's in
Star Wars and Pedro Pascal who's a man
of Lauren and you know Amanda Lauren
season two they have um Katie Sackhoff
who plays Boca Katana the animated and
and then in the live action and now
Merle Dandridge as Marlene yeah exactly
and and
and there was something there that like
I like Katie sackhoff's performance in
Mandalorian but
I was a little bit more aware of what
they were doing whereas here it it just
I'm not that I'm more like appreciative
because I know the character Marlene but
I wasn't uh but it just melded so
naturally too and I was I was kind of
dazzled by how natural everything felt
absolutely and I love that introduction
scene we got with uh Bella Ramsay and
Merle Dandridge with uh Marlene and
Ellie that that was yeah that was such a
I mean because again in the video game
as you all know or for those of you who
haven't played it uh we see the the
first scene is where Ellie tries to stab
Joel with the knife uh you know after
Marlene brings them back so that was
really cool seeing that scene getting
the setup for their relationship just
how she put her in uh you know in the
the federal military Camp uh in Boston
and that you know there there is a
history there so I just I really thought
that was such a great setup for their
relationship because we didn't really
get to spend a lot of time with Marlene
and Nelly in the video game so just even
that that one little scene right there I
really appreciated that yeah because
there are things that are that are gonna
happen that I imagine the plot of this
will has to go that we won't go into
right now but you you
they do talk about like Marlene's
emotional investment in Ellie and we
didn't really get to see any of that in
the game
and here they gave us that and I was
like oh yeah that's clever it just
sounds like a little moment like don't
point the gun at her point and I mean
just little things like that what you're
saying the trust with the yeah oh yeah I
haven't had a clue but also the trust in
the like with that when he when she does
give give her the backpack and the knife
and then she just sits right close to
him like oh that's great you're building
the bond
yeah yeah without spoiling [ __ ] like
good stuff's to come that's good stuff's
coming and and I I think the changes
they make are smart like sure what I
have liked the mission with Robert yeah
but you know when I think back on the
game I'm not like Ben that is such such
an important plot point I'm like now you
can it that that's showing that that's
showing you kind of the lifestyle of
what they get and it leads into the
Marlene stuff but they gave us other
things to show you like how they make
money and rations oh and I like the
inclusion of how he's looking for Tommy
yeah because that's not in the game not
at all and so to and but I you know I
like obviously Tommy would come back
around but the to start off there again
that just makes it more personal that
that that creates a thread of of a bunch
of more things to make you look forward
to stuff so I think if you
haven't played the game like it's not a
change to me that upsets me I'm like no
that's smart for television yeah that
makes it more and because now you're
like okay when's Tommy gonna what's
Tommy been up to like we have an idea
but as an audience member you're like
what's going on there why we can't we
get a hold of Tommy yeah no if you make
changes for the better that serve the
plot in an interesting and satisfactory
way then I'm I'm all for it I still have
the the mission from the video game so
it's not the end of the world again if
it betters the plot and is done in a
very satisfying way I'm all for it and
that that uh getting rid of the whole
Robert mission that didn't bother me in
any way shape or form no I mean you got
some cool violence in the Rock they
share in the game it shows you how
violent Joel's but see Dad get to see
that with the guards exactly so that was
fine that's why it's a great choice
because it it's the introduction of the
impact of showing how violent Joel can
get
whereas in the game that is with like
with the Robert stuff and they're like
shooting some people it's like it seems
like they're choosing which moments to
show the violence or the violence has an
emotional impact for the characters
versus sometimes in the games you're
just like killing people and not only
that I like that Ellie got to see right
away how how crazy Joel can be too so I
thought that was an interesting choice
because again I don't think in the video
games you saw that side of Joel that or
that quickly I mean because I mean
they're only 5-10 minutes into their
mission it seems like at that point when
she sees him just you know going Raging
Bull on the guys so I mean I thought
that was again just a bold and
interesting choice that serves the plot
and done in a satisfactory way and one
last thing uh I really love the last
thing I feel like I talked for hours
I really did like the whole symbolism
and the whole theme of just out of time
with showing all the clocks and the
watches and all that because I mean it
was basically just a countdown to the
world just completely changing and
flipping on its heads yeah I thought
that was again just really wise choices
the cinematography and the steps episode
the sound design it was really well for
I mean it really didn't feel like an
hour and 19 minutes I was like I
couldn't believe the episode was done I
had to remind myself that there was a
camera
I was like oh yeah yeah I need to
sometimes say something because I was
like I was back to just playing the game
yeah it was like quiet and paying
attention yeah yeah no it was really
really strong first episode and the
music too okay Gustavo sent out him I
think it's great because they I've
definitely played some I've definitely
seen some video game adaptations where
I'm like I'm familiar with the game and
I watch it and I'm like oh this just
seems manipulative or pandering and this
was the first time I was watching this
like really experiencing as an avid game
lover of they are they are really
bringing this to life in a way that
feels more than satisfactory
um
just for one second like you're so
shocking Gabriel Luna's voice I don't
remember oh the Tommy Boy that was just
unbelievable what the [ __ ] what does he
sound like exactly like it's like did
they have Jeffrey Pierce like doing the
debit nods Gabriel Luna like that's that
was really really impressive like the
first time you said I was like it did
sound alone then I heard a couple more
lines like holy crap it sounds just like
just like it was not like an
impersonation it naturally sounds like
Tommy then they do stuff to specifically
make game lovers get excited about [ __ ]
you know like when they are doing the
Sarah scene in the car where they go
into her perspective yeah I'm like oh
man they are recreating this
specifically more than just like that's
how it is in the game so we have to do
it yeah they do [ __ ] where you're like
the game lovers are gonna love this and
I'm like yeah this is working for me and
they also they did a fake out too
because nor in the game the car hits uh
they crash a car crashes into them and
then in this the car almost crashes into
him fake out and then you got the
airplane that lands a great touch good
touch no I thought that was really again
really so so uh subvertive and like it
but done in an interesting and
satisfactory way I feel like that's
going to be a common theme of words I
use a lot on this show if this first
episode is anything to run by but
fantastic first episode again even if I
wasn't a massive fan of this I'd really
love this first episode but being a
massive fan like this is again just
first episode one of the best video game
adaptations I've ever seen just from a
first episode I know that's a quick
remark to make after the first episode
but this was just really really well
done like and again I try making this a
movie at first I'm like what are you
nuts
it's got it it'd have to be like I've
been saying it for years that like video
game especially ones that are so story
based yeah they have to be TV shows yeah
you need to spend more time with these
characters if this show remains
consistent for the remainder of the
season
it's we have a revolution videos
yeah no it is a it is a testament to
like no this is why video games should
be television shows yeah and and just
this pilot alone which has only
scratched like barely scratched surface
yeah we're barely like the in the game
you're like oh oh the missions finally
started yeah and that's what where it
leads you on um I think it's so smart I
can't wait to see how some of the action
scenes are done yeah but it but it
doesn't feel like they're gonna do
action scenes seems they're gonna do
violence you know and I think we'd be
remiss tonight it really quickly
mentioned I thought they nailed the look
of the clickers like just put the hair
out of the mouth and that scary tension
Vibe like yeah we haven't got our
full-on we got first thing I didn't say
clicker I said Runner you say clicker I
did oh okay sorry play it back it's the
Colorado uh Snapchat in my brain but now
I I the runner the runner I'm sorry I
think you were right it's a quick the
runner the runner that we saw at the
beginning uh the neighbor at the Adler's
house I believe they said I thought they
and some of the other Runners that we
saw like God I love this stuff
the 10 the tension you feel I mean I
made a comment saying this it really
feels like a John Carpenter film like I
was really doing a good job of building
tension in a way like in the game you do
feel that but it's it's hard to describe
the differences you feel when you're
watching it like actually like
cinematically on a TV show but I thought
they did it just a great again that's
that's the Nuance of balances that I'm I
already loved in this first episode
there's so many different things that
they were able to to accomplish and
really balance out so really really good
first episode well with the game you
have to you you are the player you're in
control you're in control so you're in
it and so with a show you do have to
expand because you have to do more work
to make the audience feel in it yeah you
just have to because there's already a
natural subconscious thing that happens
as as the player versus when you're not
actually the player you have to do more
work and be and be and that more work I
think is they definitely paying off to
make you feel more
to make you feel more involved
I I do think with Bella Ramsey she's
really capturing the essence and there
are times in her performance and I'm
like sometimes it still feels like I'm
aware you're acting but for the most
part I wouldn't say that for the most
part I'm like I'm loving what you're
doing Petra Pascal is killing it oh yeah
Pedro Pascal is just [ __ ] yeah he's
an alien and just really quickly on
Bella Ramsay I I from I can totally
understand sympathize with what you're
saying I think from a perspective of
just the foul mouth smart ass like she's
got that portion down in my opinion so
far so far yeah I think I think actually
yeah it's first episode yeah no first
episode but no I'm I'm curious to see as
we spend more time and we expand upon
the show like I'm I am more curious to
see just you know how more into
character she gets as Ellie because so
far I like her I like her I I like her I
haven't fallen in love with her yet but
not much time has been spent right you
know and and uh and we have to see the
development of the relationship with her
and Joel because that's the heart of
everything right of course
um and then like okay if that's down
then I'm like boom yeah we're holding
Hook Line and sink or if you get that
relationship down
I was really impressed yeah that was
great they [ __ ] did it man I did it
the the build up to that that was a
great first episode they and I love
where they ended it too like that was
perfect ending as well like great yeah
because it's setting up themes character
Mission at hand and now um going to the
other side of the wall you know like oh
we're about to really see some [ __ ] like
you have not seen anything at all no no
and even story-wide like more than
visuals like story-wise yeah yeah it's
just oh there's so much more to tap into
that you know they're going to if if
this first episode's a testament at all
to where they might go yeah
um I'm excited I uh I I really loved it
and uh now now this is why I wanted to
watch this with a fellow gamer yeah
because that was that was amazing yeah
that was great I was so impressed with
that I was so impressed with that uh
yeah well what'd you guys think of the
first episode did you love it what
qualms did you have
um be curious to know be curious to know
subscribe leave a like and uh hey we'll
we'll catch you all soon follow Andrew
thank you guys for being here
[Music]